[Música]
[Aplausos]
é dessa forma que eu chego nas feiras e
ganhou minha vida meu nome é karine
priscila
sou dona proprietária modelo e estilista
da alegria a modas
tanto que ultimamente as pessoas só me
chama de grita e sempre gostei de moda e
e foi muito bom porque eu conseguir
transformá la em profissão
de repente eu conheci o turbante e nele
descobrir que não era só um acessório de
moda e sim de luta e resistência e
através disso queria saber mais sobre a
etnia sobre a cultura sobre o que é ser
livro comecei tem informações através da
internet facebook e youtube de amigos e
percebi que o empoderamento não é só
ostentação de bens
esse de conhecimento porque a partir do
momento que um negro sabe o que é ser
negro ele consegue entender de todas as
dificuldades que acontece em nossas
vidas
a solidão da mulher negra a
hipersexualização do negro
a alta taxa de desemprego o coloristas e
outras coisas a mais que poderia ficar
aqui a tarde inteira falando pra vocês e
com essas informações
eu consegui transformar minha vida tanto
do lado pessoal ea profissional e com
isso comecei ser ponto de referência e
as pessoas perguntavam onde tem turbante
e falavam
a economia grita e aí eu comecei a
entender que eu tinha que fazer uma moda
afro
quero uma coisa minha e assim eu comecei
ser mais conhecida e mais pessoas
começaram a me chamar pra participar de
feiras tanto afros e as feiras mistas e
pra mim foi muito bom porque eu comecei
a ter uma identificação com os negros
que também enfrenta as mistas
porque se a gente quer igualdade
respeito a gente tem que estar em todos
os lugares e assim foi de lugares e
lugares de feiras e feiras até chegar na
capital
chegando na capital eu conheci outros
elementos da da cultura afro livros
brinquedos
eu achei maravilhoso porque eu não vi
isso aqui
então pensei por que não trazer pra cá
livros de repente ser um pouquinho
difícil para mim mas os brinquedos não
posso costureira por que não fazer
as bonecas negras de pano e daí surgiu
as boletas
e minhas melhores inspirações
foi através das minhas amigas porque
minhas amigas são todas coloridas e
cabelos coloridos roupas coloridas assim
como eu e quando comecei a fazer mostrar
elas sentiram super bem porque elas
estavam se vendo o produto que não tem
muito no mercado boneca negra e boneca
negra de pano e colorida nossa acho que
foi a melhor invenção que eu fiz na
minha vida até agora e e foi legal
porque sem identificação foi através das
crianças e também dos adultos porque a
partir do momento que um adulto começou
a consumir uma bolha e grita ela estava
recuperando um pedaço da infância que
não teve porque tipo assim eu não tive
uma boneca negra e isso pra mim foi
emocionante e receber fotos das crianças
brincando com as bonecas sabendo do nome
de cada boneca eu tenho várias bonecas
que chama andar a lupita sbed china
belinha e isso é muito bom e eu descubro
gente ser negro é tão belo
é tão lindo seus traços sua pele seu
cabelo e falando de cabelo eu tenho uma
história pra contar pra vocês eu deus na
minha adolescência
minha mãe ela não tinha condições de
ficar fazendo alisamento pagando
alisamento de 33 meses
então por conta própria decide cuidar do
meu cabelo crespo e assim foi na minha
fase adulta
eu fui comercializar o cabelo e fazer
outras técnicas
depois eu comecei a me sentir incomodada
porque eu queria desconstruir o que a
sociedade impõe esse padrão eurocêntrico
que coloca no negro porque o negro tem
que realizar o cabelo porque o negro tem
que cantar igual uma pessoa europeia mas
não somos europeus
e aí eu fui e coloquei firme
eu vou voltar com o meu cabelo crespo eu
vou me amar novamente eu vou cuidar do
meu cabelo porque meu cabelo é lindo ele
é forte ele é marcante e simplificar
melhor essa minha negritude com o cabelo
eu fiz uma música e essa inspiração vem
num momento muito chato da minha vida
porque eu estava andando na rua toda
feliz bela como black enorme maravilhoso
aí de repente veio duas pessoas rindo do
meu cabelo ano entende por que porque
eles estão rindo do meu cabelo no cabelo
e resistência e para essas duas pessoas
estava sendo sinônimo de piada e naquele
momento eu consegui entender a busca das
minhas raízes e ainda continua buscando
em cada conversa em cada feira em cada
sorriso e cada histórias de negro que
esbarra na minha vida
e naquele momento surgiu uma frase eu
não tenho culpa se o sustento a minha
negritude no dia seguinte acordei mais
negra letra mas preta mesmo mais
empoderadas do que nunca e terminei de
cantar determinei escrevi essa música
que agora vou cantar pra vocês
eu não tenho culpa se o sustento minha
negritude
eu notei ocupar-se sou mais negra que
você eu só não entendo por que vir do
meu cabelo wo no cabelo é crespo crespo
é sempre vai ser o que eu sou negra do
cabelo crespo cristo é e sempre vai ser
assim não entende o meu cabelo crespo
buhr paradise e comece a entender
[Música]
meu cabelo crespo r a identidade do meu
cabelo crespo é lindo de viver
o cabelo é meu aceita que dói tendo rui
meu cabelo crespo e crespo é sempre vai
ser o que eu sou e quebrar o tabu de
lucro mesmo cristo é e sempre vai ser
e não impede o cabelo crespo e que
coubesse ae
o castelo que desculpa pelo cansado o
cabelo liso ou relaxado não é contratual
que você quer respeitar o próximo a você
a mulher tem que ter união terá a nova
geração
eu sou errado tá é crespo é e sempre vai
ser
[Música]
eu sou celebrado o cabelo crespo e sei
que meu pai se caso houvesse a entender
[Música]
obrigada